monsieur le président cinq minutes
monsieur bonsoir madame jouer nike
mustang issue big top on sort avec tout
le package on est d'où il vient
tout le monde sait que vous avez fait ce
qu'il fallait sur ce point même le
président le sait vous devez réapprendre
à vivre dans le monde réel
monsieur le président nous sommes prêts
nos invités sont arrivés
bienvenue à la maison blanche ce
monsieur
monsieur il ya eu une intrusion venez
vite
c'est pas là
wauquiez
passez-moi le pentagone maintenant
que la paix tomber l'olympe est tombé
monsieur vous devenez président par
intérim je veux parler aux russes et aux
chinois aux britanniques et aux français
dans cet ordre si vous tentez de
reprendre ce bâtiment j'exécuterai votre
commandant en chef
thiais
nous avons un contact dans la maison
blanche veuillez vous identifier
03/09 c'est pas vrai baning et que le
gars qui a été viré de la garde du
président il a appartenu aux forces
spéciales
40 commandos sont entrés il en reste 20
est-ce qu'il est fiable
sauf votre respect
je suis votre seul espoir
avant de les abandonner il s'agit de la
sécurité du président des états unis
il s'agit de bien plus que ça à monsieur
il est ouvert les portes de l'enfer
états unis d'amérique ne négocie pas
avec les terroristes
qui vous a parlé de négocier